bridgeton is back with all the bodice
ripping ball dropping unchaperoned
action you've come to know and love a
handbag
i'm sorry i randomly found that clip and
will likely use it a half dozen times
throughout this video after the huge
success of season one season two has
large shoes to fill especially
considering the absence of the duke of
hastings simon arthur henry fitzranoff
bassett yes that's his real full
character name apparently actor rejean
page left the show amicably but if i
were lady whistled down i'd suspect some
behind the scenes scandal afoot alas
this video isn't about that it's about
season 2 it's ending in what we may
expect from season 3. and don't worry
there won't be any spoilers from the
books partially because i can't read do
you read
books i've also left timestamps to the
topics i'll be covering below so sit
back enjoy some light refreshments is
that cake and make sure to like and
subscribe because we're going to have a
ton of fun
oh the puns get worse whereas season one
focused on the relationship between
daphne bridgerton and the duke of
hastings season two's main plot revolves
around daphne's older brother anthony
and newcomer kate sharma if you thought
daphne and the duke had it rough just
wait till you see these guys express
their love you were the bane of my
existence
kate has arrived back in london with her
stepmother mary sharma and half sister
edwina sharma this is all under the
guise of finding edwina a suitable
husband because secretly the sheffield's
mary's affluent parents have said they
will bequeath their sizable wealth
edwina should she find and marry a noble
englishman of course edwina doesn't know
this what could go wrong since the
moment you arrived you have failed to
show the proper respect for the sharma
family and i will not stand for it i
will
stand for it
in the second last episode of the season
kate frustrated about her feelings for a
man that has been betrothed to her
sister rides into a storm and is knocked
off her horse her solo rides have been
something she's done throughout the
season symbolic of her yearning to be
free both from her duty and a society
that dictates who she can and cannot
love it is ironic then that the person
who ends up saving her is the very man
she met while riding back in episode 1.
throughout the season kate and anthony's
love has been hindered by one thing duty
i'm looking for perfection mother and
you should be too this is the duty i
must fulfill for anthony love is the
last thing he's looking for when it
comes to finding a suitable wife love is
the last thing i desire but if my
children are to be of good stock then
their mother must be of impeccable
quality he treats the courting process
as a duty to be performed setting up
interviews and rehearsed questions
without factoring love into the equation
because for him it is part of his
familial duty it is only out of the
greatest love of my family that i aim to
choose a bride with my head and not my
heart anthony is a slave to duty and
this largely stems from what happened to
his father edmund bridgerton anthony had
much love for his father but when his
father died to an unfortunate bee sting
anthony closed off his heart for him it
was better to shield oneself of pain and
choose not to love than to risk it and
feel that sorrow like he did when his
father died but then after your father
died a wall went up inside you as if
love had become some
some weakness fun fact edmund's favorite
flower was a lilac and wouldn't you know
it but in the vast majority of scenes
you'll see kate wearing that color like
here here and here so if anthony is to
overcome his sense of duty and embrace
love he'll need to learn a valuable
lesson from his mother that it is better
to have loved and lost than to have
never loved at all and i would
undoubtedly feel the same pain i felt
all over again if i had to because real
true love is worth it like anthony
kate's duty to her family prevents her
from finding true love specifically to
her sister edwina to whom she has put
all her time and energy into finding a
match kate is not looking for a husband
at all i'm not here to find a husband
for myself only for my sister it isn't
until episode 6 that kate reveals the
true reason why she will not marry after
her biological father died mary and
edwina took her in treating her as their
own and she will not allow herself to
find love until mary and edwina are
taken care of i promised i would not
consider myself until you and mama were
taken care of kate has been vicariously
living through her younger sister
teaching her everything she needs to
know in order to thrive in high society
what this is actually created is
resentment in her sister for treating
her life as if it were her own you have
spent your life trying to give me
everything i lacked
but really you simply gave me everything
you really wanted for yourself as though
my life were not my own if kate is going
to find true love she like anthony must
put aside her familial duty and realize
that she is deserving of love ironically
enough it is the two mothers who give
both anthony and kate that push to
follow their hearts and express their
love to one another at the featherington
ball after eight episodes of pent up
will they won't they anthony proposes to
kate and she says yes because i cannot
imagine my life without you and that is
why i wish to marry you the season then
fast forward six months after the
marriage of kate and anthony and the two
are happily in love and can finally
express their feelings towards one
another in front of everyone and i half
expected the duke to make an appearance
here saying did i miss anything but a
happy ending is not in store for all our
characters at the end of season 1 it was
revealed that penelope featherington was
the salacious gossip queen lady whistle
down who is actually voiced by none
other than julie andrews in retrospect
it makes sense that pen is whistled down
she has access to all the high society
soirees keeps mainly to herself at the
balls where she picks up on all the hot
gossip and doesn't have men swooning
over her 24 7 affording her ample time
to write these columns as eloise
bridgeton penn's best friend states of
whistle down another thing that the only
reason mrdan writes about such things is
because she is not an actor participant
in them a better word here would be
active participant so at the start of
season 2 we've learned that whistle down
has taken a bit of a break but with
cording season just around the corner
she's ready to sharpen her knives or
should i say quills it's funny then that
in the first scene between penn and
eloise this season she is buying quills
but someone very powerful is adamant on
uncovering whistle down's true identity
and that is the queen the power whistle
down commands in high society is only
matched by her at the stroke of a quill
whistle down can destroy lives which is
why if her identity were revealed it
would be ruinous for penelope the queen
devises a plan to find whistle down's
identity and ultimately one of her foot
soldiers finds eloise visiting a local
print shop little does the queen know
that eloise has actually fallen in love
with a print shop employee
theo sharp and that eloise herself was
searching for whistle down's identity so
the queen corners eloise saying she must
work for her and write good things about
her in the columns or else she'll be
destroyed this puts eloise in a
precarious dilemma because she isn't
whistle down in order to save her friend
penelope must do something unthinkable
write something so terrible about eloise
to prove that whistle down isn't her and
that's exactly what she does stating in
the next column that eloise has been
fraternizing with political radicals
unchaperoned no less a handbag
the plan works but eloise is ruined
making it that much more painful when
she discovers that her best friend did
this to her during the featherington
ball eloise notices how penelope has
picked up on certain gossip and she
begins to put two and two together going
so far as to ransack penelope's room and
finding her secret stash of whistle down
money and effects it's a complete
falling out between these two both of
them saying things that will undoubtedly
make it difficult for them to repair
their friendship but if there's one
thing for certain it's that the writers
are putting penelope in a place where
she is utterly alone at the start of
season 3. she's lost her best friend no
man desires her and the only person she
truly cares for colin bridgerton is
overheard saying that he'd never dream
of courting her if this isn't the start
of a villanark i don't know what is at
the end of the episode penelope picks up
her quill stating that whistle down
cannot keep quiet for long with eloise
knowing her identity i'm not exactly
sure how she's going to keep up this
charade but who knows maybe eloise will
have to keep quiet with what penelope
has on her or perhaps eloise's
credibility is already tarnished
regardless expect a more spiteful
whistle down next season from one
featherington to the other we now take a
look at the baroness porsche who after
the death of her husband archibald in
season 1 eagerly awaits the arrival of
the next owner of the estate jack
featherington porsha hides the fact that
her family is on the cusp of bankruptcy
thus she devises a plan to entrap jack
into marrying her daughter so they can
access his vast wealth in the mining
industry that is until she finds out
he's on the verge of bankruptcy too so
what do two desperate people do
obviously work on an even bigger scheme
to fool the wealthy elite of london into
investing in their sham mining company
so they can take all their cash and run
away to america it's actually colin a
potential investor who uncovers this
plot finding out that the gems he's been
selling are a cheap knockoff knowing
they'll be found out porsche ends up
double-crossing jack taking half of the
money and setting him up as the sole
antagonist of this devious plot and this
is all because jack truly does not care
for her or her children remember this is
the guy who wanted to make out with
porsha even though he was engaged to her
daughter and it's clear to me that you
do not care about them at all so i'm
sending you away with your favorite
person yourself not only that she had
mrs varley forge a signature stating
that as soon as one of her daughters has
a son the estate will pass on to them
this actually sets up some juicy drama
for season 3. it may force the
featherington sisters into competition
with one another to see who can pump out
a sun the quickest in order to gain
control of the estate but there are
still a few loose ends when it comes to
the end of the season and the start of
season 3. we know that netflix has
renewed bridgeton for a third and fourth
season and that executive producer chris
van dusen has stated his goal was to
focus on a different bridgerton sibling
in every one could that mean benedict is
our season 3 lead he did drop out of art
school after finding out his brother
paid for his entry so that's all up in
the air but van dusen has stated that
they quote might have to get creative
when riding these upcoming seasons that
to me signals they aren't going with the
obvious next bridgerton sibling benedict
i'm wondering if that will mean we could
get a time jump and possibly see an
older hyacinth or gregory be the focal
point of next season anything seems to
be on the table colin is also a
possibility however i personally see him
as a bit too young to take on the lead
just yet maybe in two seasons from now
bridgeton's aside we also have edwina
who was supposed to be wed to anthony
she's now single and as the queen hinted
at near the end of the season she's
gonna try to hook her up with her nephew
the prince of russia who we saw briefly
in season one if that actually happens
it means kate and anthony would be
brother-in-law to russian royalty which
i think opens a ton of cool new
possibilities i'm really excited to see
where bridgeton goes it looks like every
season will have its own unique feel and
spin to it which will make it exciting
to watch but what did you think of
bridgerton season 2 i want to hear your
thoughts and theories in the comments
below thanks for watching everyone be
sure to like and subscribe it really
helps the channel out and for more bad
takes you can follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember
you